we're happy to report that 10 dw
correspondents working in afghanistan
have now been able to leave the country
following its takeover by the thalibon
the correspondents entered neighboring
pakistan earlier today this group
includes dw's sole female correspondent
in afghanistan the situation for
journalists on the ground has become
increasingly dangerous with reports of
intimidation and violence at the hands
of the taliban joined now by one of the
dw correspondents marjana sadat who
joins me now from the phone from
pakistan majana thank you for taking the
time to speak with us i want to start by
asking you you were able to leave
afghanistan what are your feelings right
now
thank you for having me on your program
uh as you know uh there was no hope for
the future anymore in afghanistan but at
on that time i decided to uh
be on this situation and work and want
to speak to write and uh for portraying
most of today's narratives even it's a
was even it was uh done by secretly but
uh we decided to write about the uh
material of the land and to portray of
the displacement of our people and our
generation there and it's it was for uh
our history uh so i i didn't experience
those uh dark days and you know the 15
years back was the best days of my life
and the other woman's in afghanistan i
studied we went to universities worked
with the
most prestigious international media and
i unlike me
many women in various fields of works
and those days were just our golden days
of our lifetime and it's finished just
three weeks ago when the taliban took
over the afghanistan marjana you see the
golden days of your lives basically
taken away that day when the thalibon
took kabul what were your feelings that
day when you saw that was taking place
uh actually on that day uh i was uh i
was outside outside the home and i
wanted to go and record the reports from
kabul university i was in german
department and public university my
colleague called me and told me that
taliban is into
entertaining kabul and you need to uh
come to office on the first time i came
down uh they are coming down or on our
block and asked the guard who is living
here in this block i was looking at them
throughout the window of my apartment
and i just shocked because i didn't
experience of
the taliban regime uh before so um now
uh as in the past i can't
freely hold my camera and take pictures
and videos from the uh of the cobble
roads interview with the people freely
and like me any or or other journalists
as well uh they cannot
do their uh job like freely and uh go to
a roots and without any fear and they're
in kabul
marjana thank you we're relieved to hear
that you're safe and sound and thank you
again for speaking with us
the u.s is preparing to mark the 20th
anniversary of the 9 11 attacks the
terrorist strikes using hijacked
airliners killed nearly 3 000 people
events are taking place across the
country students at this new jersey
school have installed 2977
flags on the front lawn that's one flag
for each person killed when the jets hit
the world trade center in new york and
the pentagon in washington a fourth
plane crashed in a field in pennsylvania
the u.n development agency has warned
that afghanistan could soon be on the
brink of economic and social collapse if
no effort is made to support the economy
they say that takeover by the taliban
has put more than 20 years of gains at
risk and that large parts of the country
could be plunged into poverty by the
middle of next year the comments come as
the international community faces off
over whether to unfreeze billions of
dollars of funds belonging to
afghanistan and currently held in the
united states
some say the risk of not doing so could
leave millions hungry and generate new
waves of refugees but the u.s says it
has conditions
if a new afghan government upholds its
commitments and
obligations brings greater stability to
the country and region
demonstrates real inclusion
and protects the gains of the past two
decades
will work with it
but we will not do that on the basis of
trust or faith alone
the taliban seeks international
legitimacy and support
our message is simple
any legitimacy and support will have to
be earned
but pakistan is urging a different
approach its foreign minister called for
the assets to be unfrozen and for the
international community to step in to
avert a humanitarian crisis in
afghanistan calling it a collective
responsibility
but what we are saying is okay
if you're not ready
for immediate uh
economic aid or development
fine
but
do not take steps
that would uh
you know lead to
an economic collapse
of afghanistan
that will not help
that will not help anyone
and pakistan for its part has already
begun sending aid to afghanistan the
country delivered a first shipment to
kabul of 30 tons of supplies including
food medical equipment and medicine the
pakistani government says deliveries
will continue in the coming days and in
the next round relief planes will land
in kandahar herat and khost provinces
but pakistan's involvement in
afghanistan extends far beyond aid the 9
11 terror attacks meant it was to play a
pivotal role in u.s operations and
policy in afghanistan a prime reason for
that was pakistan's support for the
taliban it formed the basis of
cooperation and confrontation with the
united states we'll talk about that in
detail in a moment but here's a quick
summary of how that relationship has
played out over the last 20 years
in the wake of the 9 11 attacks
pakistan's leader general pervez
musharraf declared pakistan would join
the war worn terror as a us ally
in return for the lifting of sanctions
and billions of dollars in aid pakistan
provided the u.s with a number of
military airports and bases for its
attack on afghanistan
along with other logistical support
but the alliance between the two
countries was always shaky marked by
distrust from both sides
many taliban members had been trained in
religious schools in pakistan and
fundamental islamists still held
considerable power
while helping the u.s militarily
pakistan was also harboring taliban and
al-qaeda terrorists
in 2011 10 years after it launched its
war on terror the us tracked down and
killed the mastermind behind the 9 11
attacks osama bin laden
it turned out that he had been holed up
in a secure compound in pakistan
that led many in the u.s to question how
the world's most wanted terrorist could
have been hiding in plain sight in a
country that was supposedly an ally
but the u.s too did much to draw
pakistan's anger continued drone strikes
on taliban targets in pakistani
territory stoked anti-us sentiment
many pakistanis felt they were a
violation of their sovereignty
and hundreds of pakistani civilians as
well as soldiers were killed by u.s
drones
leading to huge demonstrations
more recently pakistan used its
influence with the taliban to act as a
mediator in peace talks between the u.s
and the islamists
but how frail the bond between pakistan
and the u.s really is became clear after
the u.s troop withdrawal from
afghanistan
pakistan's prime minister imran khan
made no secret of his feelings saying in
afghanistan they have just broken the
chains of slavery
with the u.s mission in afghanistan over
and the taliban now in charge the
relationship between the u.s and
pakistan is set to be redefined
joining me now for more is michael
kugelman he's deputy director of the
asia program at the wilson center in
washington dc michael welcome now since
taking office u.s president joe biden
hasn't yet called pakistan prime
minister imran khan i wonder what that
says about the state of the bilateral
relationship
well i think it's an indication of how
this relationship is is
transactional and in other words the
administration is not going to have a
call between the president and prime
minister khan just for the sake of
having the call i think that you would
get a call between biden and imran khan
only if there's something something
major to discuss whether a new agreement
for instance a new say intelligence
sharing agreement to help with
counter-terrorism activities in
afghanistan or something like that
you know the biden administration may
consider pakistan as a partner to an
extent but certainly not a close ally
and i think that the ideas that suggest
that there really is no reason to have
such a prestigious call so to speak
unless there is something really major
to highlight or to discuss
and why does america view this
relationship to be so transactional
well i'd argue there's nothing wrong
with the transactional relationship
first of all in fact the us has very few
relationships that one would describe as
strategic which i think is the logical
opposite of a transactional relationship
uh certainly the us has strategic
relationships with some of its closest
allies such as the uk and israel and
australia but uh most of its
relationships are transactional i think
with pakistan there's just a lot of
divergent interest and there have been
for quite some time
you look back over the last 20 years you
know clearly there's a lot of
disagreement when it comes first of all
to classifying what constitutes a threat
and a terrorist threat obviously
the u.s looks at how pakistan has
treated terrorist organizations
terrorist groups like the haqqani
network
and lashkar-e-taiba it sponsors these
groups the us sees them as as enemies
and the us also believes rightfully so
that pakistan has oftentimes sheltered
the very groups that the u.s wants them
to target and i think given those levels
of divergences and interests and those
levels of mistrust it's very difficult
to think that there would be enough good
will and trust to be able to forge a
deep strategic partnership now with that
having been said how do you see the
relationship with pakistan shaping up
now with the taliban a group that
pakistan has supported in the past
running afghanistan
well certainly i think that pakistan has
clearly gained a major strategic victory
in the sense that for the first time in
nearly 20 years it will have a
friendly government in kabul so to speak
which has long been
pakistan's goal
and you know that entails
opportunities for pakistan to step up
its its role and its footprints in
afghanistan in very uh in very overt
ways and of course it also means that um
it will be very more difficult for india
which for
much of the last 20 years had been
arguably afghanistan's closest partner
in south asia but i think india's
influence and its leverage in
afghanistan is really going to suffer a
big blow know what this means for the us
and pakistan
that remains to be seen for quite some
time the u.s has sought to enlist
pakistan in efforts to
press the taliban pressure the taliban
to to do things that would conceivably
help u.s interests in afghanistan most
recently that is entailed trying to get
the pakistan to get the taliban to the
table for negotiations
and more recently to try to get the
taliban to stop staging violence this
worked to an extent it also did not work
to an extent but i think that that same
pattern will likely continue as we move
forward um but it's very hard to to know
at this point how the relationship play
out because the us is for all intents
and purposes it's left afghanistan and i
think that it feels that for its limited
goals in afghanistan right now which
entails things like getting any american
remaining americans out of afghanistan
ensuring that humanitarian assistance
can get to afghanistan the us can just
engage directly with the taliban it
doesn't need pakistan's mediation
now can i expand the the question to uh
why the u.s engagement in the
indo-pacific what is the key thing we
should be watching out for
well if you want to talk about u.s
engagement with the indo-pacific i think
that this has to be framed through the
lens of china and u.s china rivalry and
in fact one of the main reasons why
president biden decided to leave
afghanistan was to be able to focus more
intention on the u.s china competition
so i think that we will see in the
coming weeks and months efforts by the
administration to build on the momentum
of the quad grouping of the us japan
australia and india to
um
develop new areas of cooperation uh
whether that entails the pandemic or
climate change or other things and also
infrastructure i think there's going to
be a
an effort to try to build cooperation on
an infrastructure all in an effort to
push back or should i say to counter
balance um china and i think more
broadly what we're going to see from the
bible administration is to try to
build a greater global consensus um to
push back against china again using
recent developments like a new g7
initiative to develop this new
infrastructure project that would entail
trying to wean countries around the
world away from chinese
infrastructure support that's going to
be hard to do
but i think that's that's the plan now
and so i think that you know the the
administration is increasingly going to
want to have the afghanistan situation
in the rearview mirror even though it's
going to remain engaged to an extent
particularly when you look at
terrorism efforts but the focus will be
on other parts of asia particularly the
east and northeast asia the indo-pacific
we leave it there for the time being but
thank you so much for joining us today
michael kugelman
thank you